c'était énorme estime vraiment cette
histoire a coûté une femme si c'est
incroyable un jour je vais donc
j'appelle jean roch moi parce que moi
s'appelait dans la semaine comme chabal
à [ __ ]
georges appelé jean roch à 16h genre en
semaine c'était le grand manitou des
bonnes juge oui j'en ai en fait j'ai
compris eux il m'a à chaque fois que tu
dis les journées rock
gens et en fait j'ai compris gambettes
son nom c'était à mon sens c'était le
genre c'est pas ça montre bien comment
elle s'appelle monsieur roch au début
[Applaudissements]
c'est comme une autre et moi j'étais
persuadé que c'était une goût
et donc j'appelle
j'appelle gens devraient aller aux gens
oui bonjour
c'est thierry thierry bizot même si
directeur des divertissements
je pense beaucoup à toi tu sais on va
certainement faire des grandes choses
ensemble tu vas te faire faire du
divertissement et la une les relais et
où tu passes con j'ai passé samedi soir
entre 1 14
[Rires]
14 ou non que des mecs que des mecs de
m6 que des règles chiche et eu avec tout
tout l'état major de m6 maintenant tu
vois l'état major des milices et que des
copains mois mais ils n'ont pas du tout
la tête de l'état-major même fils il on
allait la tête être l'état major des
trois mousquetaires intermarché
et on arrive devant la boîte je vous
jure que c'est vrai et la voix ya des
mecs qui me connaissent mais comme ce
qu'eux-mêmes même pitch magoni les mecs
qui me connaissent voilà et y voit jean
roch qui sort que j'avais quatorze
gaillette legs la guerre doivent en
effet comme ça thierry et
l'adoption pardon pardon secret
rémy jaune m6 et dans
le cas et dans la boîte mois gêné mais
tu meures des formations en asie
ne vous connais pas monsieur il n'ya pas
l'asie si
je soutiens les bijoux dames 6 donc avec
des soufflets ccc s'est pas portée des
mesures et je vois je re qui voit des
mecs
là genre qui me met des tables des
bouteilles de partout maintenant j'ai
pas payer à nos et la gérer et toi bien
on va faire de grandes choses
je voulus à l'histoire est vraie a créé
donc tous les mecs me joignais grave
taulier donc j'étais la boîte si le
vigneron je me rappelle mes vraiment mes
souliers mais de ouf quoi vraiment et
j'ai été tirés miso et un jour le vrai
il ya une vraie leur cas c'est que ya
thierry bizot le vrai qui va vraiment on
vieillit vont à saint tropez
il essaya charly et lulu qui était sur
m6 et qui sont dans la boîte et thierry
bizot arrivons à droite il fait beau
selon le site il ya une vidéo d'elle
c'est
là il s'appelle jean roch est un terrain
dit à monsieur bisou entre faits et
c'est ça
ces révisions je connaître vous dire que
c'est pas pour ses eaux peuvent vous
dégagez et là le mec va voir charrier
lui vient il ya un mec qui s'est fait
passer pour tirer mu m6 est là donc ils
tirent au sort et voit thierry bizot
devant être annoncés le retirer
oui mais c'est pas un gars
le gars désolé entrée et donc il a fait
rentrer thierry bizot et un jour il est
à comédie d'invités et il voit un mec se
balader à poil rue pierre demoures en
sketches tirés bizot il fait comme ça
mais c'est thierry bizot
[Applaudissements]
voila voila c'était l'histoire on fera
les boîtes de nuit après que vous que je
vais pas vous demander ces dégâts